faith seems to play a role in expanding
imagination but what how what how do you
think this works do you think more of it
can be done and how do you how do you
stiff that we get people to actually
understand what is it's taken
I
probably the best thing I've learned in
the last 10 years about faith comes from
1st Thessalonians in the New Testament
where Paul's writing a letter and he's
writing the letter to the Thessalonians
and he's saying that when Sal Vedas and
Timothy and I came to you we had power
we had the Holy Spirit and we had true
conviction and what I learned from that
is the best thing I've learned in 10
years about faith and and growing is
where I when I go to a difficult place
so I'm in a difficult situation I take a
prayer partner with me this is a
practical thing and it's not it's
something that Jesus did Paul did they
were very seldom ever alone you only
tend to her alone when they were with
God but they always took people with him
and Paul says you know do this which one
more gather together I'm there if you do
this you have power and I can't tell you
how many times I've been to North Korea
the Congo when you meet and you go to
difficult places and you see people
dying and the power of two or more
together and what happens is every
morning we get up if we're on a trip and
we we would pray before the day would
start and then when we go in if I'm
meeting with somebody that's really poor
a mother or something or I'm meeting
with the Prime Minister my friend is
with me I just introduced him as an
agricultural specialist which he was but
he's praying he doesn't tell the person
he's praying he breaks I can't tell you
how many times I've seen that
conversation turn around where we leave
the country and not because we have
sparkling personalities because you know
you people are different this is really
this is some of the best conversations I
ever had it's because of what i learned
from paul that when you take a prayer
partner you have support you're stronger
you're you have the power with you and
it's it really works I mean it's the
most amazing thing that I've learned the
last name it's so simple that there's so
many lessons that we can learn from the
from the scriptures but we we bypass
them because they're too simple they
don't work and I find that when I face a
difficult situation like a fast if I ask
other people I get people to pray with
me I don't have to announce it to the
world the power is there question what
do people don't see their first is
necessary how do you how do you get
either faith or something else to help
you to see that something from home
well you know what I do the things in
front of me I don't try to save
everybody I try to you know I just go
and I do and I pray and I try to be led
by the Lord not every issue I can't you
know I can't find an answer to every
issue in the scriptures I mean you know
the far right they loved the Moral
Majority they used to love to do a
voting record on congressman and they
they always had 10 votes every year and
this is the far evangelical right and
out of ten votes I always maybe got
three right so therefore because I only
vote thirty percent of the time I can't
be a Christian but I'm looking at some
of their issues you know one of the
issues was corporation franchise tax and
I'm thinking I'm looking in the
scriptures for what Jesus says about the
corporation franchising I can't find it
and so that that gets back to one of the
issues you said that you know you can
use religion in such a way that is so
odious that it turns people off of God
and those those are some of the things
that are being done today in American
politics and a lot of other places